The ultimate goal of this project is to
really go where no one has gone before.
You want to generate
an authentic contribution
to some field based on
the information that you gather,
based on the models that you
construct to figure data.
But what that means is that you're not
going to have the same kind of support
you might be used to
when doing this project.
Eudacity coaches won't be able
to help you because you're doing
all new things that
they've never seen before.
Your peer reviewer similarly.
They might be able to give you
some idea about the strengths and
weaknesses of your approach, but they
don't have expert knowledge about how to
work in the domain
that you're working in.
And that's actually the really exciting
thing about this final project.
You're not just doing a project for
a degree program that's going
to be a feather in your cap.
You're really doing something authentic.
You're generating authentic conclusion,
an authentic analysis,
about real data out in the world.
The project that you'll generate here is
something that you should be proud to
walk into someone's office and
tell them about,
because it really represents your
mastery of machine learning.